[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 21 janvier un
nouveau confinement deviendrait
probablement une nécessité absolue si la
circulation du variant angles est
augmenté de façon sensible déclarations
du ministre de la santé qui prévient que
toutes les personnes à risque pourrait
ne pas être vaccinées d'ici l'été
les stations de ski elle se prépare à
une année blanche 1 aux etats unis
l'administration bei den au travail dans
une amérique fracturé le nouveau
président a signé une série de décrets
dès son arrivée à la maison blanche hier
soir retour des etats-unis dans l'accord
sur le climat et dans l'accord de vienne
ou remis en pause des négociations avec
les talibans en afghanistan une
politique de rupture avec l'époque de
donald trump qui lui promet de revenir
d'une manière ou d'une autre
en attendant quel bilan économies tirées
de ces années trump élu sur un programme
populiste permettant de ramener des
emplois au pays donald trump a tenu ses
promesses
le niveau de vie des américains s'est il
amélioré pendant ces quatre années
autant de questions auxquelles
notre économie dit jacques sapir tentera
de répondre tout à l'heure dans l'édito
échos
[Musique]
olivier véran s'exprime ce soir la
télévision sur la situation sanitaire
l'occasion pour lui d'évoquer la
campagne vaccinale largement critiquée
et les mesures de restriction alors que
la rumeur d'un troisième confinement se
fait de plus en plus pressante face aux
risques liés aux variants du coronavirus
ont fait le point avec katia technique
en direct du ministère de la santé
le poussoir katia que peut-on attendre
de cette interview du ministre de la
santé ce soir bonsoir c'est fanny et
bien pas vraiment de scoop en revanche
une question lancinante aujourd'hui
allons nous être re confiné bien c'est
une probabilité car envisagé le ministre
de la santé olive et veyran ce matin
même à l'assemblée nationale car les
chiffres d'une part de contamination
reste élevé 27 milles hier alors on dit
qu'ils sont dans un sens de plateau
stable mais montrent en effet 27000
c'est beaucoup plus que les 5000 qui
devrait être de rigueur
et malgré les mesures prises et le
couvre-feu à 18 heures mais il ya
surtout cette préoccupation liée aux
variants britannique à cette propagation
qu'il faut à tout prix éviter
aujourd'hui il représente 1,4 pour cent
des contaminations journalières il faut
ajouter à cela que l'europe l'agencé
européenne chargée des épidémies a
demandé aux états membres de renforcer
les restrictions face à cette
propagation possible alors je vous
propose de prendre connaissance des
discours de l'irrévérence matin tous les
laboratoires sont mobilisés pour nous
permettre d'avoir des indicateurs de
suivi de croissance du variant parce que
je rends va pas se mentir là le
développement de la propagation du
variant d'origine anglaise sur le
territoire français peut-être un élément
déterminant dans les stratégies de lutte
contre l'épidémie nous pourrions
déployés dans les prochains jours et des
prochaines semaines
et si la part de variants c'est le voc
2020 devait augmenter de façon sensible
et que nous devions suivre une
trajectoire allant gleizes le
confinement deviendrait probablement une
nécessité absolue
alors il faut
voir que certains pays ont déjà durci
les mesures comme par exemple au
portugal où on prévoit à 15 jours de
fermeture pour les écoles autre nouvelle
sur les vaccinations feiler a annoncé
que désormais on pouvait prélever si
doses de vaccins dans un flacon et non
plus 5
donc il livrera moins deux doses mais
heureusement pour autant de vaccins
et puis la mauvaise nouvelle vous en
parliez c'est les stations de ski qui ne
rouvriront pas au 1er février comme
espéré voilà et nous attendons a
désormais toutes les annonces du
ministre et on retrouvera évidemment un
peu plus tard pour ses annonces merci
katia technique en direct du ministère
de la santé
impacté également par la pandémie de
kobe de 19 les étudiants on en a souvent
parlé face à leur détresse
emmanuel macron annonce des mesures le
président en déplacement à la mi journée
sur le site universitaire de saclay dans
l'essonne souhaite que les étudiants
puissent rendre en cours une fois par
semaine au moins
autre mesure de repas par jour à 1 euro
pour tous les étudiants qu'ils soient
boursiers ou non
il proposera également la mise en place
d'un chèque si pour les élèves en
détresse qu'on va mettre en place pour
le deuxième semestre
il est sur les repas c'est de permettre
à tous les étudiants qu'ils demandent
d'avoir accès aux deux repas par jour
par les restos u à 1 euro les activités
extra universitaires qu'elles soient
culturelles sportives
on n'arrivera pas un retour à la normale
dans ce deuxième semestre parce que on
aura encore beaucoup de contraintes les
prochaines semaines je vais être honnête
avec vous vont être assez dur et la
gestion de la crise par le gouvernement
justement mais aussi le spectre d'un
troisième confinement sans oublier la
fermeture des stations ski et la
question épineuse des vaccins on en
parle avec nos invités place au
décryptage
[Musique]
mais avec nous ce soir jérôme marty
médecins généralistes bonsoir j'ai
remarqué vous est aussi président de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre vos côtés philippe moutot ce
directeur de l'office du tourisme de la
station les carreaux située en haute
savoie près de la frontière suisse
bonsoir à vous aussi arnaud benedetti
est le rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire
bonsoir a tous des trois merci d'être
avec nous alors avant d'évoquer les
mesures contre le virus la question des
vaccins arnaud benedetti emmanuel macron
on l'a vu lors d'une visite à des
étudiants s'est plaint à face aux
critiques de mauvaise gestion de la
crise de la part des français nous
sommes devenus une nation de 66 millions
de procureur at il dit
le président qui a fait l'apologie du
droit à se tromper une réaction de
l'observateur politique que vous êtes le
droit se tromper doit être assortie
aussi du droit à la critique
ce qui me paraît tout à fait légitime
dans une démocratie moi je suis assez
surpris voire déstabilisé par cette
déclaration du président de la
république qui intervient dans un
instant où l'on prépare finalement la
société française à subir de nouvelles
contraintes en raison de la crise
salutaire au moment où finalement on se
rend compte que l'opinion publique est
relativement disons calme voire résigné
même presque à accepter un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont tous les
jours un peu plus contraignantes ses
déclarations du président de la
république constitue à mon sens une
erreur de communication
parce que tout simplement elles
traduisent finalement une tension
permanente que le président exerce dans
sa relation avec le corps social à un
moment où finalement le corps social a
besoin surtout à la fois d'explication
de pédagogie et d'apaisement compte tenu
de la situation sanitaire
donc tout se passe finalement comme si
le président n'avait pas appris de ses
erreurs de communication passée lors
d'autres crises je pense notamment à la
clis des gilets jaunes et
je crois que en effet cette dernière
sortie du chef de l'état n'est pas en
mesure d'une certaine manière disons de
rassurer l'opinion publique sur sa façon
de concevoir sa relation à l'opinion
publique au delà de la crise sanitaire
c'est pas tellement le sujet de la crise
sanitaire qui que pose que coop qui pose
question dans cette dans cette
déclaration c'est plutôt tout simplement
la communication politique du chef de
l'état alors on lisait on la menace d'un
troisième confinement est sur toutes les
lèvres et notamment celle de l'exécutif
une mesure inutile selon eric chabrière
professeur en biochimie allez y a su
pardon méditerranée et proche
collaborateur du dernier raoul qu'il
était l'invité de rtl on se met à
écouter le confinement n'a pas montré
son efficacité et je pense que la
démonstration la plus fort c'est pour
l'automne uni le couvre-feu dans les
départements avec ou sans couvre feu
n'ont montré leur efficacité ou leurs
différences et en plein milieu du
confinement
le nombre de baisses de contamination a
stagné
il n'a pas vraiment repris non plus à la
fin du confinement
donc je pense que ces mesures sont
inutiles ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que dernier les vétérinaires qui
ont l'habitude de gérer des crises
épidémique dans les élevages
il ne confirme pas leurs animaux
ensemble ça ne marche pas on isole les
animaux malades pour les soigner nous on
a une approche qui est complètement
différente de bloquer les gens les gens
peuvent se contaminer à la maison cette
semaine j'étais à paris dans les
transports en commun qui était bondé
voilà on va dire les gens c'est
difficile d'arrêter une épidémie et
c'est illusoire de croire qu'en laissant
les gens plus longtemps à la maison que
ça va stopper dr marty alors
qu'effectivement ce deuxième confinement
a montré ses limites qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire aujourd'hui quand on parle
comme ça de 3e confinement quel est
votre avis de médecins ce qu'il faut à
confiner ou laisser plus de liberté aux
français aujourd'hui
il ya plusieurs choses dans votre
question d'abord le confinement a montré
son efficacité
le seul problème c'est qu'il ne s'est
pas sorti de l'est certainement
y aurait permis de poursuivre son
efficacité c'est à dire que quand on a
enlevé en particulier le dossier à
l'époque finalement elle était déjà trop
en termes de plateau on n'a pas voulu
s'attaquer aux problématiques des écoles
c'est à dire ne pas fermer évidemment
les épaules mais agir sur les cantines
qui sont de véritables incubateurs
virale on n'a pas voulu s'attaquer aux
chefs d'entreprise qui sera également
des incubateurs et on a en quelque sorte
comme pony toutes les mesures qu'ils
puissent parler français qui respecte
ces mesures et qu'il faut saluer on a
tamponné avec les arrivées virale qui
venait des écoles des entreprises et
donc on a eu un plateau de 15000 même by
cathy aujourd'hui et à 26000 qui
continuent à décoller tranquillement on
est plutôt mieux placé que les pays peu
d'autres pays européens qui notamment
lors des vacances de noël ont réouvert
les pubs récupère les les pouces qui
était parce qu'ils étaient pas
l'accepter et qui aujourd'hui ont des
chiffres plus élevés je pense à
l'angleterre l'irlande par exemple et
puis on a cette problématique de
variants qui accélère de plus en plus
qui risque de prendre la place
mathématiquement du virus qui est sur
notre territoire en creux aller le 15 km
du 15 février au 30 mars dans la
situation la plus pessimiste est puis
fin mars de la situation un petit peu
plus optimistes mais qui nous impose
d'être beaucoup plus efficace alors tout
le monde de créer un confinement un
nouveau confinement parce que les
conséquences sociales sociétales
économiques sont extrêmement importantes
de plus en plus importante confinement
après confinement mais on voit bien que
malheureusement dans certains
départements on a on est en train de
vivre des choses qu'on n'avait jamais
rencontré jusqu'à présent avec des
accélérations de nombre de cas d'un
certain ehpad en particulier dans le
sud-est qui sont du domaine quasi de
l'explosion
et donc il faut qu'on regarde ça de
façon extrêmement extrêmement précises
de façon à prendre des mesures tout ne
pas attendre trop et nous on prône
plutôt si c'est un couvre-feu commis les
faits il doit s'accompagner de mesures
sur les cantines sur l'ailé les
entreprises comment parler et si on va
au confinement
alors là il faut sans doute plutôt viser
un gonflement européen c'est à dire que
vous ferment tous
même temps qu'on vaccine très vite
pendant ce temps de confinement et qu'on
puisse en faire et ouvrir avec en
quelque sorte les compteurs à zéro
plutôt qu'à voir ce qu'on a connu depuis
le début un pays qui fait reléguer ou un
autre qui ferme à notre mouvement et le
virus qui circule comme ça de l'un à
l'autre sans clé effectivement ça semble
être un voeu pieux cher docteur marty
parce que le la même chose dans tous les
pays européens on en est loin et la
question des vaccins on en parlera
précisément avec vous un petit peu plus
tard en tout cas ceux qui veulent
retrouver une activité qui paient un
lourd tribut à ce sont les stations ce
qui en est certainement qu'il y aura des
confirmations tout à l'heure au journal
de 20 heures deux de nos confrères de
tf1 d'olivier révérend à ses stations de
ski qui a priori resteront fermés c'est
une saison morte qui semble pendre au
nez de ces professionnels vous propose
tout d'abord la réaction du syndicat
national des remontées mécaniques et des
domaines skiables avant de vous faire
réagir
concernant les remontées mécaniques
le gouvernement n'a pas baser ses
décisions sur des éléments rationnels
mais sur des préjugés de montagne
exubérante et de comportements débridée
loin des réalités des clichés qui prouve
un manque de connaissance et de
confiance la montagne mettra des années
à s'en remettre
2 mars 2020 à décembre 2021 c'est
presque deux ans de fermeture
deux ans sans recette ni trésorerie les
dispositifs d'indemnisation doivent
inclure tous les acteurs des stations
très fine hypothèse on imagine votre
désarroi aujourd'hui la montagne qui
mettra des années à s'en remettre
comment vous allez faire nous avions
encore un mince espoir jusqu'à ce début
de semaine est là le couperet est tombé
hier de tout état de cause donc on s'en
doutait un petit peu quand même hein les
réseaux malgré la posture de ira tout
prix il faut opérer en février on voyait
bien le dense on voyait bien le nombre
de personnes contaminées donc il fallait
se rendre à l'évidence que ça serait
compliqué de que les stations ouvrent
pas tant que sur le pays sur les
télésièges on puisse être distancié mais
ces brassages de population c'est et à
mener
des centaines et des centaines de
milliers de personnes aux sports d'hiver
dans les magasins de sport et on sait
que là on ans le docteur disais tout à
l'heure c'est un lieu des changes par
rapport au virus donc c'était s'était
pas tenable voilà donc maintenant la
décision es prise ce qui va vite falloir
avoir c'est une visibilité c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qui a confinement au port est
ce que les stations vont ouvrir sans les
remontées mécaniques en février et qu'on
va faire un produit station or ce qui
avec comme à noël avait autour du ski de
fond autour du ski de randonnée autour
de la raquette
voilà et espérer qu'on pourra où est ce
qu'on va confiné vous à moi si on
devrait même les remontées mécaniques
maintenant ne jamais on aurait rempli et
au niveau financier économique les
stations se seraient pas retrouvés
aujourd'hui vous discuter des
compensations économie ni faux ni
et comment compenser cette perte au
niveau des stations de ski mais
également des marais de sport qui n'ont
pas eu de fermeture administrative
donc c'est complexe mais on s'y
attendait vraiment c'est pas une grosse
surprise c'est vrai que la posture de
domaines skiables de france du des
moniteurs des parlementaires était
logique devait se battre jusqu'au bout
mais la décision est plus bien plus haut
il ya des raisons sanitaires connais
personnellement le directeur de d'aidé
d'urgence de chambéry me dis que c'est à
flux tendu c'est pas possible
donc il faut se rendre à l'évidence la
santé d'abord c'est sûr si atypique on
l'a jamais connu une année blanche comme
ça pour les stations de haute altitude
savez terrible nous les stations
villages on pourra peut-être faire quand
même quelque chose de correct peut-être
à -50 et -60%
mais c'est très dur à accepter en tout
cas vous êtes plutôt voilà compréhensif
et c'est tout à votre honneur jérôme
marty c'était nécessaire cette fermeture
parce que certainement que ces stations
elles vont peut-être restés ouverts on
va peut-être pas empêché voilà des
stations il ya des locations
d'appartements de rester accessible au
public les gens vont quand même se
brasser c'est vrai que quand on voit
vous l'avez dit vous-même certains
centres commerciaux bondés le samedi
après midi on peut se poser la question
on aurait été peut-être mieux pour que
certains français dans la neige avec des
masques à prendre l'air ça fait du bien
au moral
aussi non donc c'est l'évidence mais
vous savez le l'économie qui tourne
autour du ski c'est nous
juste devant 10 et des déplacements de
population pas seulement d'ailleurs la
population qui viendra pour le loisir
mais c'est aussi le déplacement d'un
travailleur vous allez quantité de
saisonniers qu'il faut embaucher qu'on
va dépasser si vous ouvrez maintenant
alors même qu' il y à une menace de
confinement dans quinze jours vous
comprenez aisément que la chose est
extrêmement difficile et est quasi
impossible il ya ces gars sympathique
qui se pose est particulière nous on
défend des la possibilité puisque je
suis innocent donc pyrénées on défende
et la possibilité de laisser les
stations ouvertes à la journée pour la
clientèle régionale c'est à dire que
vous avez quantité de ville où les gens
vont inscrire la journée ils partent le
matin ils rentrent le soir
il ya donc pas d impact sur les
infrastructures hôtelières avec des
risques de concentration sur les petits
appartements à plusieurs il ya le
scénariste les contaminations en plein
air sont quasi d'asie extrêmement que
l'on peut dire le minimal est
inexistante
donc le vrai risque est effectivement à
la concentration dans les magasins mais
vous l'avez dit les grandes surfaces
sont ouverts que les centres commerciaux
sont ouverts donc avec avait comme conan
les précautions
c'est tout à fait possible mais mais
mais on a ce orient on a à la menace du
confinement et donc on a laissé passer
peut-être le temps on aurait pu ouvrir
qui était celui de l'emi décembre
jusqu'à maintenant il a maintenant c'est
quasi impossible
arnaud benedetti on a entendu un
philippe le dos plutôt compréhensifs
mais tout même beaucoup de français
s'interrogent sur cette cohérence des
mesures du gouvernement
encore une fois on vient d'en parler les
centres commerciaux bondés les
restaurants fermés mais les cantines
ouvertes les stations ski fermer
également quand il ya quand même
certains
échanges notamment dans le sport les
activités sportives à l'extérieur a
paris il ya de la cohérence dans les
décisions du gouvernement selon vous
face à une situation qui est très
difficilement maîtrisable et on s'en
rend compte et où finalement il ya très
peu de visibilité ou les projections
d'un jour sont très souvent infirmée par
les projections du lendemain il est très
difficile pour l'action publique de
bâtir une stratégie qui puisse
apparaître cohérente
on voit bien que finalement toutes ces
mesures qui sont d'ailleurs foncièrement
différenciées les unes des autres qui
vise finalement adapté de manière quasi
plastique là là la réponse publique à
l'épidémie entraîne des incompréhensions
vous l'avez fort justement dit pourquoi
il fit n'est fermé des restaurants et
laissé ouvert des restaurants
d'entreprise pourquoi fermer un certain
nombre de commerces comme ça a été fait
lors du premier confinement et maintenir
les écoles ouvertes et maintenir les
métros bondés qui circulent dont on nous
dit d'ailleurs selon certaines études
mais je ne sais pas lesquels qu'il
serait moins contaminant que les cafés
et des restaurants
je crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui une grande
difficulté pour l'action publique de
pouvoir apporter de la cohérence à
l'opinion publique parce que tout
simplement on navigue à vue et on l'a
tous compris depuis le début de cette
épidémie et on n'est pas les seuls en
l'occurrence le manifestement c'est le
cas de la plupart des pays qui sont
confrontés à cette épidémie
mais je crois quand même que sur le fond
il y a un souci c'est à dire que on se
rend bien compte que dans l'histoire
récente toute récente de cette épidémie
ce qui a été le mieux compris depuis le
début c'était le confinement généralisée
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où au
mois de mars lorsque le gouvernement a
décidé à l'instar d'autres d'autres pays
d'avoir un consultant généralisée il y a
eu là de la part de l'opinion publique
compréhension de cette mesure
aujourd'hui on a un pilotage qui est
encore une fois un piment et un pilotage
qui est policier mais on voit bien et ça
ça me semble plus important c'est que on
est en train de de préparer de
conditionner de manière très suggestive
en tout cas l'opinion publique à un
nouveau confinement qui à mon avis aura
lieu dans les jours ou en tout cas dans
les semaines qui viennent en raison
notamment de ce nouveau variant
britannique il salue aussi le variant
sud africain qui pas pour rêver ça
envoie un certain nombre de problèmes
notamment sur le vaccin
donc on prépare les esprits mais le vrai
problème c'est de savoir quelle sera la
nature ce constat ce confinement numéro
2 plutôt qu'un confinement numéro un je
ne suis pas sûr que là ça soit
véritablement compris là aussi par
l'opinion publique
chacun faisant un usage très personnelle
de se constituer lors de la de la
deuxième phase c'était l'objet de ma
remarque quand j'ai essayé de vous
couper effectivement savoir que non non
je vous en prie je vous en prie qu'est
quel type de confinement effectivement
parce que l instant à olivier ferrand
dit si la situation se dégrade nous
prendrons des mesures difficiles mais il
ne précise pas lesquels précisément le
vaccin justement vous en parliez olivier
vers en parle aussi puisqu'il admet ce
soir un surbooking
ce sont ses mots en la matière les
vaccins jérôme marty on avait une
polémique avec vous et notamment qu'est
en train de naître sur
l'approvisionnement justement du vaccin
fait hier vous avez passé un coup de
gueule sur twitter docteur je vous
propose d'écouter kaiser biotech se fout
bien de notre gueule
vous savez que les médecins de terrain
ont mis en évidence le fait que l'on
pouvait avec du matériel adapté et une
technique protocole is est prélevé sido
à partir d'un flacon annoncé à 5
eh bien le laboratoire réagi covit 19
fire considère qu'un flacons de vaccin
contient 6 dose et adapte ses livraisons
car vous n'êtes pas le seul à poser ce
coup de gueule à d'autres médecins vous
ont rejoints et cette polémique est en
train de monter comme on dit sur les
réseaux sociaux si on comprend bien
jusqu'à récemment le laboratoire livrer
les pays acheteurs sur la base de cinq
doses de vaccin par flacon maintenant ce
sera 6
qu'est ce que ça change quel est le
problème pour d'un qu'on comprenne
énormément de choses ça change
énormément de choses d'abord ça pose
plusieurs questions
effectivement on avait mis en évidence
les médecins l'avaient mis en évidence
le fait qu'on pouvait faire si doses à
partir de 5 go ce but de l'acsel d'un
style d'un cycle là il essaime a publié
cela et avic effectivement un c'était
exact et donc freezer a saisi la balle
au bond et adib et les peintres à
s'embraser sur les doses comme vous
pouvez faire si d'ozap axionov la côte
de st on va vous livrer 20 % d'être là
qu en moins ce que ça change c'est que
windows qui était une dose bonus
surnuméraire en quelque sorte que l'on
faisait qui nous permettait de vacciner
un patient en plus on passe à une dose
qui est obligatoire en quelque sorte
comment la colonnade bancaire à chaque
fois et ça ça impose que l'on ait le bon
matériel or nous n'avions pas là pour ça
il faut bien comprendre
pour l'instant les médecins se
débrouillait bien souvent ils amenaient
leur propre aux aiguilles et parce que
les aiguilles été livré par là des faits
est à la direction générale de la santé
n'étaient pas les bonnes
or pour arriver à faire si dose il faut
avoir des aiguilles qui n'ont pas de
volume mort comme très peu de volume en
libéral et d'un d'avoir des aiguille
sertie dans les semaines et là vous
arrivez à le faire tranquillement à
chaque fois mais ce n'était pas le cas
et d'ailleurs dans son communiqué la
direction générale de la santé dans le
communiqué qu'à la sentir la paix m
je croyais recevoir nous dit que elle
rassure tout le monde qu'elle va donner
le protocole il est gentil on n'est pas
tendue mais calme a aussi livré le bon
matériel mais que ne l'at elle pas fait
plus tôt
elle va livrer le bon matériel donc là
on est relativement inquiet parce que
soit il est là ce matériel mais à ce
moment là elle pouvait le livret soit
elle ne l'a pas et on retombe dans la
problématique des masques au mois de
mars
on va acheter des serait le sertit un
moment où la demande mondiale
on m'assure t 1 et concurrence
internationale et on risque de ne pas
être livrés donc non seulement on va
avoir les process qui aujourd'hui pour
être ralentis parce qu'on fait peser la
responsabilité des six doses sur les
équipes vaccinales qui vont être obligés
de faire extrêmement
la 6ème lowe's contiennent bien les
ennemis les héros de poids militent aux
cris et donc vont aller plus lentement
parce que par prudence on va faire c'est
s'il ose et on doit garantir aux
patients qu'il est bien vaccinés dont
maxime à moins de patients à chaque
heure mais surtout on n'est pas du tout
sûr que l'on recevra la dotation en bon
matériel et donc au niveau relativement
rapidement je voudrais laisser le mot de
la fin philippoteaux ce genre
d'information tout de même est ce que ça
n'augmente pas encore plus la défiance
de la population vers les autorités
alors là c'est pas les autorités mais
les laboratoires
c'est vrai que ça ne donne pas confiance
à son gendre une confusion et un climat
douteux qu'on fusionnant pour les gens
est clairement on voit bien que tu as
sont sur la vaccination depuis le début
notamment en france il ya aujourd'hui de
gros doutes sur la façon dont cette
campagne vaccinale est organisé
d'ailleurs les médecins généralistes
même se sont plaints d'être
insuffisamment associés et on peut les
comprendre à cette campagne alors qu'ils
sont quand même la première ligne pour
les la plupart des françaises et des
français dans la relation à la à la
santé ce qui est sûr c'est que on voit
bien que sur aujourd'hui cette question
de la de la vaccination
on a le sentiment de finalement
reproduire le mauvais film que l'on a
connues et le docteur martin a très
justement rappelé lors du début de
l'épidémie avec les masques puis les
tests la question est de savoir si
finalement au-delà des questions
industrielles qui sont réelles si l'état
a fait un véritable retour d'expérience
tels que sastre à tic dans les
entreprises en règle générale de
finalement des manquements qui ont été
les siens lors de la première campagne
si je puis dire de cette crise et on
peut se poser des questions en effet si
en l'occurrence on a tiré toutes les
leçons en matière d'organisation et de
logistique pour justement aborder dans
les meilleures conditions cette campagne
de
de vaccination le mot de la fin pour
vous philippe pauzat puisque vous êtes
près de la frontière suisse de nombreux
français vont se rabattre en suisse
malheureusement peut-être ou
heureusement je ne sais pas pour eux
mais qu'est ce que ça vous inspire quand
on voit que ces stations suisses restent
ouvertes et que tous ceux qui peuvent
pas aller skier en france et qui n'en
peuvent plus de ne pas pourvoir prendre
l'air aux vont aller skier en suisse ce
sera ma dernière question
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on voit les images
qui remonte des webcams de 10 à attendre
dans les stations suisses on se demande
comment ça se fait que des pays laisse
quand même encore leur station ouverte
donc on râlait un petit peu maintenant
la clientèle qui va sur ses stations
suisses elle y va par opportunisme on
sait qu'elle reviendra dans les stations
françaises c'est pas tellement sahin qui
nous fait souci aujourd'hui il faut que
la montagne pour ce mois de février
reste reste adaptable il va pas se
réadapter avec cette nouvelle décision
il va falloir se montrer solidaires
solidaire avait avec tout tissu
économique et social de la station et
puis responsable aussi également par
rapport aux gens qui voudront venir en
février les stations qui ont ouvert en
suisse c'est bien ou bénéficier d'
opportunisme temps je dirais tant mieux
pour eux mais il ya quand même les
choses les quotas les restaurants ne
sont pas ouverts les bars n'ont plus
faim c'est pas quand même la panacée je
connais le directeur de verviers ont
discuté avec simon est oui y est c'est
pas quand même le top
alors maintenant écoutez nous c est acté
sa semaine saison blanche pour les
remontées mécaniques mais mais la
montagne peut exister quand même février
on va attendre savoir si un confinement
ou pas si on pourra faire des animations
des activités qu'elle comme on pourra
séduire une clientèle en février à quel
moment pour essayer un petit peu de
dernier de baume au coeur un peu à nos
futurs vacanciers
merci en tout cas bon courage à vous
merci jérôme marty merci également à
arnaud benedetti d'avoir été avec non
directe ur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nous partirons aux états unis
illustration maiden déjà au travail dans
une amérique facturer le nouveau
président signé une série de décrets dès
son arrivée à la maison blanche puis
nous tirant le bilan économique du
mandat de donald trump avec l'économiste
jacques sapir
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pierre gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt francs si vous
nous rejoignez 20h30 heure française joe
biden se met au travail dans une
amérique divisée à peine installé à la
maison blanche le 46e président des
états unis a signé une quinzaine de
décret pour tourner la page trump les
explications d'emilie kogas revenir sur
les mesures phares prises par donald
trump
c'est un peu la première décision de joe
biden dans le bureau ovale il a signé 17
décret présidentiel
ils doivent permettre à la nouvelle
administration de faire face aux crises
multiples que traversent les états unis
certaines des mesures exécutive que je
vais signer aujourd'hui vont contribuer
à inverser le cours de la crise du coc
vide et nous allons combattre le
changement climatique comme nous ne
l'avons jamais fait jusqu'ici et faire
progresser les kits et raciales et
soutenir les autres communautés mal
desservies
nous allons également reconstruire notre
économie pour lutter contre la
propagation du cauvel 19 qui a fait plus
de quatre cent mille morts dans le pays
joe biden a rendu obligatoire le port du
masque dans les bâtiments fédéraux une
agence rattachée à la maison blanche
doit désormais et coordonner l'action
sanitaire contre le coronavirus en
pleine pandémie son arrivée à la maison
blanche marque également le retour des
états unis au sein de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
donald trump s'en était retiré en mai
dernier
il l'accusé d'avoir mal géré la crise du
coronavirus autre mesure phare elle
concerne la politique en matière de
changements climatiques
joe biden qui souhaitent rejoindre
l'accord de paris d'ici à un mois de la
trump s'était retiré de cet accord peu
après son investiture
enfin le 46e président des états unis
met fin à la construction et au
financement du mur à la frontière avec
le mexique une construction engagés par
donald trump coup d'arrêt également à un
décret migratoire font trop versé le
muslim ban
il interdisait aux ressortissants de
pays en majorité musulman d'entrée aux
états unis
et vous que pensez vous de ce départ de
donald trump et de l'arrivée de joe
biden on vous a posé la question je
trouve que il ya des façons de
s'exprimer aux gens où un peuple ait
lieu en fait il ya des moments bas on a
l'impression qu'il a pris les gens en
fait pour beaucoup il s'est cru dans la
téléralité savait recherché
il a pris les gens pour comme s'ils
étaient dans une télé réalité comment il
parle et quand il s'exprime sur les
femmes ça j'ai pas trop aimé parce qu'en
président se doit de représenter une
image d'un pays donc il doit être
respectueux mais par contre sur sa
politique économique à avant de kovy
gerald à dire un souvenir de ce mal-être
de
de méfiance par rapport aux démocraties
telles pour les présentes aujourd'hui
faire telles qu'elles ont été présentées
notamment sous son règne entre
guillemets notre homme c'est un
président qui me faisait peur il avait
l'air assez fou dans ses idées et que
vous valez
[Musique]
vais pas l'air très rassurant quand je
suis assez content que
il est échangé président fois que les
cours se passent sont toujours très
pauvre et au niveau de la santé et a pas
d'avancé puisqu'il a il a refusé
on pense que c'est tout près danseuses
pour le peuple américain et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis
houston aux états unis avec dave perkins
analyse politique pro trump assez notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir des perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on en parle
moi aux états unis parce que évidemment
c'est l investiture hier de joe biden
qui a pris toute la place comment
réagissent les pros trump après
l'officialisation de son départ de la
maison blanche ce qu'il y ait une forme
de résignation fouilles se rappeler
lorsqu'on parle des partisans de donald
trump que trump n'est pas le coeur n'est
pas d'accord et notre occupation ne
s'agit pas d'une secte basé sur une
personnalité
c'est pour moi une grande partie des
américains
parti très large des américains qui
connaissent bien la constitution les
lois fondatrices du pays qui sera non
pas encore aujourd'hui concrètement je
me sens impliqué et là aux amendements
nous est que tout ce que fait le
gouvernement fédéral et qui les gardent
les états les régions et les villes
devraient a décidé de beaucoup de sujets
que c'est approprié le gouvernement
fédéral n'en prenez pas légal ce n'est
pas une bague ornée au niveau que je
suis tu vas voir un seul gouvernement
qui étant de pouvoir sûr tant les
décisions qui structurent la vie des
gens donald trump est arrivé on va de
manière très franche
parfois il l'utilisé dans l'eau a séduit
enfin mais en tout cas il a remis au
centre des préoccupations ce que devrait
être la vie américaine pour la liberté
notamment la liberté de faire ce que
l'on souhaite sans que les états unis
récupère les fruits de votre labeur
delwarte qui vous empêche de faire
sauter la déclaration d'indépendance
permet de faire ce n'est pas une secte
c'est un mouvement un retour vers les
textes fondateurs américains
les gens sont reconnaissants envers
delattre heures pour son service et et
cherche maintenant d'autres voies pour
avancer dans ce programme
washington a l'impression donnée d'avoir
construit un mur mais ils seront surpris
mais vous dites c'est pas une secte
effectivement donald trump qui on le
rappelle quand même à rassembler 75
millions de 20 ans aux états unis le 3
novembre
c'est le jeu on le voit le nouveau
président à signer des décrets qui
annulé certaines des décisions de donald
trump par donald trump l'avait fait
avant lui il ya quatre ans pour annuler
des décisions de barack obama
quelles sont les décisions que les
républicains aujourd'hui regrette le
plus c'est sur lesquels joe biden
revient il a supprimé le projet
d'oléoduc de gazoducs qui apporterait à
tout public à celui là à des raffineries
c'était un projet qu'obama n'accepte pas
trop la tringle validé et je baille on
devait mettre un terme
donc ce sont des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui vont perdre leur emploi
alors que il voulait travailler jusqu'à
l'arrivée du virus
obama a également relancé la
participation qu'elle est à vue et à
l'accord de paris cela va rendre la
situation difficile va renforcer les
impôts pour toujours les grandes
entreprises et pour la population
américaine sans aucun retour immédiat à
part
ce service qui est le contrôle du climat
je suis un peu méfiant je ne pense pas
que le climat nous écoute que je ne
pense pas qu'il va faire ce qu'on me dit
de faire
je pense que dépenser de l'argent pour
ce sujet c'est de l'argent perdu
obama comme cobayes temps de penser le
contraire et maintenant nous devons
verser de l'argent à d'autres pays car
nous sommes pour le coni'fer et ça je ne
pense pas que nous devrions être puni
pour cela je pense qu'on devrait plutôt
nous essayé essayé de nous imiter et les
accords de paris elles font au contraire
que la liste des récits pseudo donald
trump serein à verser rapidement que
possible car joe biden et son équipe
voit que la mémoire même d'autres en
soit c'est effacer de la mémoire du
public de washington du gouvernement à
qui ils veulent que ça soit comme s'il
n'avait jamais existé pour deux raisons
pour lui et pour avoir l'air de l'humour
afin que le prochain donald trump voit
ce qui est arrivé à notre humble à
patienter les couturiers et des sites
peut-être deux à ne pas limiter de ne
pas se porter candidat à la présidence
c'est une façon d'influencer l'avenir en
faisant un exemple de donald trump alors
défaire keynes l'ancien président a
laissé une lettre à son successeur que
joe biden a qualifié je cite de
généreuses est-ce que vous avez une
petite idée de ce qu'il aurait pu lui
dire non à 2030 est un gentleman une
personne d'âge une personne gentille
afrique il fois que la compétition est
terminée
une fois ce n'est plus la peine de se
battre il est assez élégant si gentille
assez aussi donc toute autre personne je
pense que c'était une lettre être très
généreuse effectivement qui lui a
souhaité bonne chance
on en parle évidemment depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines mais plus que jamais
en tout cas pour les partisans dont vous
faites parti de donald trump comment
vous voyez le le futur proche on a parlé
de la création d'un parti mais il faudra
d'abord que le président sortant
franchise certains obstacles judiciaires
n'est ce pas cela rentre dans cette
émission dont je vous parlais il ya
quelques instants
il s'agit de rendre la situation aussi
difficile que possible notre pour donald
trump afin qu'il a servi d'exemple que
la situation semble trop complexe pour
d'autres qui voudraient imiter son
exemple donc effectivement cela rentre
dans cette punition qui continue une
fois la présence terminée mais s'il ne
résiste pas à le détruire complètement
je pense qu'il va commencer à un empire
médiatique où il va a lancé d'une
nouvelle chaîne à un empire sur internet
si aucun de ses objectifs depuis très
longtemps et je pense que maintenant
qu'on se rend compte que les médias
traditionnels américains dérive vers la
gauche vers le démocrate et bien il ne
pourrait les populations pourrait
décider de se tourner vers cet empire a
créé par donald trump
cela serait vraiment une chance pour
donne un train qui pourrait offrir une
voie un peu plus conservatrice dans les
médias et je pense qu'il a le nez creux
en matière de finances et je pense qu'il
s'en tirera bien je n'imagine pas
commencer un nouveau parti je pense que
c'est trop compliqué parce c'est
valorisant les médias à nos pires des
médias conservateurs
je pense que c'est une une solution
intéressante merci beaucoup d'experts
qui nous avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir est partout sur la
planète les réactions se multiplient
pour accueillir l'arrivée
de joe biden à la maison blanche si la
majorité des dirigeants se félicitent
d'une nouvelle ère dans les relations
internationales
les réactions semblent plus mitigées
dans la péninsule arabique notamment
thème embardée l'investiture du nouveau
président américain a été salué par de
nombreux dirigeants notamment en europe
la chancelière allemande a manifesté son
enthousiasme en commentant les premières
décisions prises par joe biden il y à un
éventail beaucoup plus large d'accord
politique avec le président biden si
vous regardez simplement les décret qui
ont été signés hier honshu vous pouvez
voir que nous pouvons travailler
ensemble à nouveau sur l' omc
nous avons travaillé ensemble à nouveau
sur l'accord de paris sur le climat nous
avons probablement une vision plus
similaires sur les questions de
migration à londres boris johnson a lui
aussi accueilli favorablement le nouveau
président le chef du gouvernement
britannique espère retrouver en
l'amérique un allié de premier plan
quelques semaines après le départ
officiel du royaume uni de l'union
européenne c'est une chose fantastique
pour l'amérique
c'est un pas en avant pour le pays il a
traversé une période difficile et pour
nous et pour l'amérique
c'est un grand moment nous avons des
choses que nous voulons faire ensemble
quand nous voulons rebondir ensemble
après le qu'ovide travailler ensemble
pour unir le monde et la façon dont ils
s'attaquent à une pandémie qui nous le
ferons dans le cadre du g7 du g20 en
israël où une majorité de la population
souhaitait la réélection de donald trump
benyamin nétanyahou a certes remercié le
président déchu mais a aussi félicité
joe biden le démocrate et même qualifié
d'amie par le premier ministre israélien
qui entend bien pérenniser les acquis
inédit de l'ertms rome monsieur le
président byden vous et moi entretenons
une chaleureuse amitié personnelle
depuis de nombreuses décennies
je me réjouis de travailler avec vous
pour renforcer encore l'alliance
israélo-américaine pour continuer à
étendre la paix entre israël et le monde
arabe et pour relever les défis communs
au premier rang desquels la menace posée
par l'iran à téhéran justement le départ
de donald trump réjouit la classe
politique des réactions sans surprise
l'iran ayant particulièrement souffert
des sanctions prises par washington lors
du mandat de donald trump ce qui était
vendeur conspiraient comploter contre
l'iran sont partis avec la grâce de dieu
le second projet ont été renversés en
dormant charme et godin peu
d'enthousiasmé en revanche dans la
péninsule arabique
même si la majorité des dirigeants des
pays du golfe ont adressé leurs
félicitations nouveau président
américain
la presse préfère rester modérée comme
ce quotidien saoudien qui se contentent
d'un simple au revoir trump bienvenue
maiden au royaume du bahreïn cette autre
journal regrette tout de même le départ
de donald trump en soulignant qu'il
mérite
remerciements et reconnaissance beaucoup
craignent notamment un retour à une
politique trop conciliante avec l'iran
près alors que joe biden devient le 46e
président des états unis quel bilan
économique tirées des années trump élu
sur un programme populiste promettant de
ramener des emplois au pays donald trump
at il tenu ses promesses le niveau de
vie des américains s'est il amélioré
pendant ces quatre années et plus
généralement dans quel état les ch'ti de
la première économie mondiale à son
successeur
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques un bon soir stéphanie
alors jacques ce bilan économique de
donald trump et du trump isme
globalement positif comme on l'a souvent
lu et entendu
alors oui il est clair que le bilan est
plutôt positif même si il faut dire que
cette année la dernière année du mandat
de trump a été quand même terriblement
perturbé par la coved 19
alors oui effectivement c'est donc à
mende c'est donc si vous voulez des
résultats positifs sur la question de la
croissance sur la question du chômage
mais en même temps il faut souligner
qu'il y avait eu dans le mandat de trump
une réforme fiscale extrêmement
avantageuses pour wall street et donc on
peut se demander si donald trump n'a pas
finalement choisi wall street contre
mainstreet vous connaissez cette
expression américaine qui veut dire
choisir les milliardaires contre l'homme
de la rue alors jacques comment les
américains jeu style cn et trump sur le
plan justement de l'économie c'est ça
qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est de
voir que les jugements sur l'économie et
donc sur donald trump dépens de tout à
fait de l'appartenance partisane des
gens et on l'a vu avec les sondages de
sortie des urnes
après l'élection présidentielle si vous
voulez les gens qui considéraient que
l'économie américaine était florissante
et bien ils ont voté à 78 %
pour donald trump les gens qui
considéraient que l'économie était
plutôt en crise ils ont voté pour 80%
pour joe biden même chose si vous voulez
les gens qui considèrent globalement que
leur situation que que l'économie va
bien et bien et ce sont des gens qui ont
plutôt voté pour donald train et les
gens qui n'ont pas considérer que
l'économie était quelque chose
d'important pour les choix qu'ils
avaient fait en termes de président eh
bien ils ont plutôt voté pour joe biden
donc en réalité cette question de
l'économie
elle est aussi une forme de division
entre les électeurs de train et les
électeurs de joe biden alors est-ce que
ce jugement avait conforté par les faits
oui tout à fait alors si on regarde le
taux de croissance
il est évident que au moins dans les
trois premières années de son mandat
donald trump à assurer une croissance
voulue tout supérieures à ce qu'avait eu
ses prédécesseurs
alors si vous voulez il y avait eu les
deux mandats de barack obama le premier
mandat avait été quand même marqué par
la crise de 2008-2010
il y avait eu avant les deux mandats de
george w bush et le dernier mandat avait
aussi été affecté par la crise de 2010
mais si on prend par exemple le meilleur
mandats de george bush le meilleur
mandat de barack obama est bien on
obtient des taux de croissance qui sont
inférieurs aux taux de croissance qui
ont été obtenus dans les grosso modo
trois premières années du mandat de
donald trump donc oui effectivement sur
la croissance
donald trump a comme on dit fournit des
résultats tout à fait intéressant et
comment cela s'est il traduit
concrètement pour les américains
alors pour les américains ça s'est
d'abord traduit par un niveau d'emploi
tout à fait important et ça c'est
quelque chose de de trait fondamental si
vous voulez les statistiques de l'emploi
montrent que le taux de chômage alors
que ce soit le taux de chômage officiel
où que ce soit
le taux de chômage un petit peu dérivé
qui regardent plutôt l'emploi précaire
et l'emploi des des personnes qui sont
en dessous d'un mi-temps bons que ceux
sous quel que soit l'indicateur que l'on
utilise et bien là on voit que très
clairement le taux de chômage a
fortement baissé et que à la fin de 2019
au début de 2020 en réalité on était
arrivés sous donald trump à des taux
d'emploi qui était supérieur au taux
d'emploi qui avait pu être ce que ce
soit soudeur de bouche ou évidemment
sous barack obama et même sous clinton
donc il y a à l'évidence un succès la de
donald trump alors pourtant jacques il
ya eu des mesures qui ont davantage
avantages et les grandes fortunes comme
la réforme fiscale par exemple
oui c'est évident c'est évident et dès
donald trump a pris une réforme fiscale
qui a énormément avantager les plus
riches qui a comme on dit a avantagé au
wall street contre mainstreet bon
maintenant il faut qu'on avait un petit
peu modérer ce jugement en rappelant qu'
une grande partie de la classe moyenne à
travers les fonds de pension et bien
elle retrouve son intérêt dans la hausse
de wall street une hausse qui était
absolument spectaculaire et là encore si
vous voulez un point est intéressant
parmi les électeurs des deux camps 48%
considérer que leur situation était
meilleure en 2020 en dépit de la crise
yoko vide qu'elle n'était en 2016 alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que sur ses
48 % qui pensaient que leur situation
s'était améliorée
72 % avaient voté pour donald trump et
26% pour joe biden alors japan on a
aussi beaucoup parlé de cette action de
donald trump par rapport aux traités
multilatéraux quel bilan auquel bilan
est un peu de temps alors en tirer
effectivement c'était un point important
dans la politique de donald trump et là
il ya plusieurs choses à dire la
première c'est que effectivement donald
trump s'est retirée du traité
transatlantique à ce qu'on appelle le
taffetas il a provoqué une renégociation
de ce qu'on appelle le traité de libre
échange de l'amérique du nord l'alena ou
en américain le naphta et pointent
encore plus important et c'est peut-être
le point qui avait donné le plus
d'espoirs aux gens il avait introduit
une clause de salaire minimum de manière
à pouvoir justement contrer les
pratiques de dumping social donc de ce
point de vue là il a fait pour le coup
là des choses plutôt positive mais il
et pas seul imagine jacques oui
étudiants il ya d'autres aspects qui
sont des aspects plus négative alors le
premier aspect plus négative évidemment
c'est la politique des sanctions et la
politique très unilatérale menée par
donald trump en continuité là il faut
quand même le souligner avec la
politique qu'ils avaient mais qui avait
été menée par barack obama
et puis surtout il y a le conflit
commercial avec la chine conflit qui a
été extrêmement important on est arrivé
entre les deux pays à une forme de trêve
ou de paix armée avec l'accord qui a été
signé à la fin de 2019
bien sûr les états unis ont obtenu
quelques avantages mais ça a été très
loin d'être tous qu'ils avaient voulu et
on comprend que sur ce point on restera
dans une situation extrêmement
conflictuel avec la chine
certainement dans le cadre du mandat de
joe biden et des mandats successifs
alors joe biden va-t-il prendre le
contre-pied de tout ce qu'a fait donald
trump actuellement s'il voulait sur
toute une série de points
il est très clair que joe biden voudra
marquer sa différence avec donald trump
d'où effectivement le décret sur le
retour dans l'accord de paris mais sur
le fond il faut bien comprendre que ça
va se jouer autour de deux choses qui
sont extrêmement importantes
le premier point c'est qu'elle relance
ou quel soutien apporté à l'économie
américaine qui est aujourd'hui
extrêmement affecté par la crise de
lakovic 19 et là on voit que les deux
présidents enfin donald trump et joe
biden était d'accord pour apporter un
soutien important
après ils différaient sur son ampleur
sur les méthodes on sait que donald
trump était partisan d'un chèque envoyé
à toutes les familles américaines à
chèque de 2000 $ les démocrates et joe
biden eux ont d'autres idées
ils veulent plutôt jouer
une relance structurelles bref mais il
ya à l'évidence la 1.1 point important
et puis l'autre chose qui est importante
c'est que joe biden a proposé de
soutenir les petites entre les petites
et moyennes entreprises american art
c'est une très bonne idée
il faut le dire tout de suite parce que
ce sont des entreprises qui ont besoin
surtout après tous les avantages qu'ils
ont été données aux grandes entreprises
d'avoir d'une certaine manière
une espèce de d'argent 22 ballon
d'oxygène
aujourd'hui le point qui est gênant dans
la politique de joe biden c'est qu'il
voudrait justement favoriser plutôt les
petites et les moyennes entreprises qui
appartiennent à des minorités
alors il vise évidemment les petites et
moyennes entreprises de la minorité
hispanique de la minorité
afro-américaine et ça si vous voulez ça
risque de créer un problème politique
sur quelque chose qui devrait être en
réalité très consensuel parce que je ne
vois pas d'américain s'opposer à cette
aide à des petites et des moyennes
entreprises et donc doucement en créant
un problème politique là où il ne
devrait pas y en avoir
c'est dommage et on peut penser que jo
bats et d'un risque de compromettre
justement cette action de relance alors
à conclure comment jugez vous le bilan
économique de donald trump à 7 un bilan
en demi teinte surtout par ailleurs si
on regarde les promesses qui avaient été
faites par donald trump lors de la
campagne de 2015 2016 si vous voulez
alors oui en ce qui concerne la
croissance et le chômage selon
l'expression américaine
il a fait le job il a trés trés de
manière très évidente fourni de bons
résultats si on commence à regarder la
question du commerce international et
des relations avec la chine
bon là on voit que le bilan est
peut-être plus en demi teinte
il n'est pas allé jusqu où il voulait
aller il n'a pas été du tout capable
d'inverser le mouvement de déclin des
états unis qui sont aujourd'hui dépassés
par la chine comme première puissance
économique mondiale
et rappelons nous son slogan de 2015
2016 à refaire des états unis redonner
leur grandeur aux états unis vous savez
mec américaine
great games à dallas de fait il n'y est
pas il n'y est pas parvenu
et effectivement peut-être le point le
plus délicat dans ce bilan c'est le
rapport qu'il entretient entre à la fois
les très grandes entreprises les gens
très riches et les gens qui sont
beaucoup moins riches et les légendes de
l'âme de la classe moyenne
et là on peut dire qu'il n'a pas eu une
politique cohérente avec son discours
qui était un discours de populisme
économique du moins en 2015 et en 2016
ce qui veut dire que la question du
populisme économique qu'ils soient mises
en oeuvre par un futur candidat
républicain où un candidat à la
candidature républicaine où qu'il soit
mis en oeuvre par des démocrates et bien
cette question reste toujours posée aux
états unis merci beaucoup je pensais
éclairage temps sur le milan sur les
défis qui attendent joe madden mercier
vous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants normalement sur les dernières
déclarations d'olivier ferrand sur la
situation du commis dans france mais
aussi sur la détresse des étudiants qui
ont reçu aujourd'hui la visite surprise
des manuels macron et puis direction
l'amérique latine où le brésilien lance
sa campagne de vaccination ainsi qu'aux
cuba
[Musique]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo l'eau
ou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule est ce c'est justement en
2015 sb c'est un peu le passage de
relais d'al-qaïda état islamique quelque
part dans notre politique internationale
est bien évident qu'il faut pas créer
les conditions à nouveau une terre de
jihad et de cet appel d'air justement où
en recrutement l'a malheureusement faire
en syrie en irak
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livrant
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
une bonne stratégie pour l'état de venir
en aide aux entreprises c'est en cas de
défaillance est ce que véritablement
l'état lève sa garantie et rembourse aux
banques
le problème de ces sociétés là il est il
est là depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps que renault ne gagne pas
d'argent en vendant des voitures quand
le marché se retire on s'aperçoit les
entreprises qui ont constitué des
réserves financières suffisantes et les
sociétés qui n'ont aucune réserve
financière et qui ont fait des dettes
considérables depuis depuis à peu près
michel daney concrètement est ce que
l'état joue gros dans un système qui
serait un système normal ils joueraient
beau hélas aujourd'hui vous avez des
banques centrales qui qui imprime tant
qu'elles peuvent donc que rome ou
soutenait artificiellement un système
qui est mort
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 21 janvier un
nouveau confinement envisagé c'est la
circulation du variant angles est
augmenté de façon sensible déclarations
du ministre de la santé ce soir olivier
ferrand qui a ajouté que la fermeture
des écoles n'était pas envisagé que 70
millions de personnes pourraient se
faire vacciner d'ici fin août soit la
population la totalité de la population
française dans l'actualité également le
la crise sanitaire en europe l'agencé
européenne des maladies appel à préparer
des mesures plus strictes quant aux
dirigeants européens
ils se réunissent ce soir par
vidéoconférence au coeur des discussions
l'éventuelle fermeture des frontières
intra européennes et le passeport
vaccinale alors que l'italie attaqué le
paper by one tech pour ses retards de
livraison en vexin approuvé dimanche la
charte des principes pour l'islam de
france semble déjà compromise trois
fédérations du fcm refuse de signer la
charte lui par emmanuel macron marine le
pen appels à dissoudre l'institution les
associations qui composent le conseil
français du culte musulman sont-elles
représentative des musulmans de france
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
olivier ferrand s'est donc exprimé ce
soir à la télévision sur la situation
sanitaire ont fait le point avec katia
technique au ministère de la santé
olivier ferrand estime que sa stratégie
était la bonne un millier de centres de
vaccination sont ouverts et il y aura
selon lui de 1,3 à 1,4 millions de
français vaccinés d'ici la fin janvier
9 millions d'ici la fin du mois de mars
et tous les français à la fin août mais
cela si et seulement si les autorités
européennes valide tous les vaccins
commandés par la france alors olivier
ferrand a expliqué que aujourd'hui la
pression sanitaire est forte
la tension hospitalière l'est tout
autant il ya des transferts de malades
mais que le couvre-feu semble être
efficace en tout cas on ne sait pas s'il
est suffisamment il pourrait aussi y
avoir un scénario à l'anglais je vous
propose d'écouter le ministre
si nous devions constater qu'ils
auraient davantage de variants anglais
et que nous étions sur une pente de
épidémique al anglaise par exemple ou si
nous constations que malgré le
couvre-feu à 18 heures la pression
sanitaire la saturation des hôpitaux
devaient augmenter alors nous pourrions
être amenés à prendre des mesures plus
dures telles que celles que les français
ont déjà connu pendant l'automne c'est à
dire ça peut aller jusqu'à un
confinement si la situation devait
l'exiger alors une nuance toutefois si
un confinement devrait se produire les
écoles resteraient ouvertes car selon
olivier ferrand le protocole sanitaire
que l'on déploie est efficace concernant
les stations de ski elles ne rouvriront
pas début février et peut-être pas du
tout en février a dit olivier ferrand
mais les emplois la montagne seront
aidés et puis il n'y a pas de date
annoncée pour la réouverture des bars et
des restaurants
il y à un nouveau geste barrière a
signalé le haut conseil en santé
publique à
estimé qu'à cause du variant il fallait
désormais respecter une distance de 2
mètres avec une personne sans masque
pour ne pas être contaminé
et puis au niveau des masques aussi une
annonce désormais seuls ceux de
catégorie 1 serait suffisamment efficace
les autres dits de catégorie 2 les
masques artisanaux faits en tissu à la
maison et bien ne serait pas assez
protecteur et pour remédier à cela des
milliers de masques seront envoyés aux
personnes en difficulté voilà pas de
scoop 1 sur les annonces d'olive et rome
et une foule de petites informations à
retenir et face à la grogne des français
sur la gestion par l'exécutif de la
pandémie de qu'ovide emmanuel macron est
quelque peu sorti de ses gonds lors de
la présentation ce matin sur le plateau
c'est clés d'un plan d'investissement
national le 1 8 milliard d'euros dans
les technologies quantiques écouter
cette stratégie elle assume
aussi la part de risque et d'erreurs et
je le dis parce que ce qui va avec la
défiance française c'est aussi cette
espèce de traque incessante de l'erreur
c'est à dire nous sommes devenus une
nation de 66 millions de procureur
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait face aux
crises aux qu'on avance et donc chacun
fait des erreurs chaque jour celui qui
ne fait pas d'erreur ou celle qui ne
fait pas d'erreur c'est celui où qui ne
cherche pas ou qui ne fait rien ou qui
mécaniquement fait la même chose que la
veille nous avons besoin d'avoir des
femmes et des hommes qui cherchent qui
ont la capacité à inventer ce qui n'est
pas encore perceptible et à se tromper
pas une déclaration lors d'une visite
surprise à des étudiants puisque depuis
plusieurs jours de nombreuses
manifestations sont organisées pour
alerter sur leur situation difficile
emmanuel macron annoncé aujourd'hui
plusieurs mesures pour leur venir en
aide
ces élèves de plus en plus plongés dans
la précarité des détails avec robin pu l
c'est un cri d'alarmé qui résonne dans
les rues de lyon
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants se sont
rassemblés ce jeudi pour faire entendre
leur détresse après que deux d'entre eux
ont tenté de se suicider au cours du
mois de janvier
privés de cours depuis près de deux mois
à cause de la situation sanitaire
les élèves se considèrent comme les
oubliés de cette crise soumis à la
précarité à l'isolément
il réclame à présent des actions
concrètes aujourd'hui on adapte
simplement parce que on est en situation
difficile pour les étudiants sur le plan
psychologique elle sur le plan financier
avec beaucoup déçu gens qui sont en
galère qui nombreux flux qui veulent
pouvoir retourner à l'université qui
peuvent ils veulent pouvoir avoir les
moyens de pouvoir étudier convenablement
nuit la couverture des facultés en
hybridation avec une tête farmer en
ligne qui fonctionne et on veut pas que
de voir l'enseignement supérieur
s'écouler ni même la précarité à
financière augmente et donc voilà je
pensais qu'on est là aujourd'hui pour
que les universités ouvrent avec le
gouvernement à la crête face au raz le
bol de plus en plus audible emmanuel
macron a pris la parole ce jeudi dans
l'essonne au cours d'un déplacement sur
un campus universitaire
le président a notamment annoncé la mise
en place d'un programme de repas à 1
euro pour tous les étudiants boursiers
ou non
autres revendications évoquées par le
chef de l'état la réouverture des
universités
un étudiant qui soit en licence au
master une étudiante
il doit avoir à peu près les mêmes
droits il a les mêmes besoins que
quelqu'un qui travaille et s'il en a
besoin et doit pouvoir revenir une
journée par semaine à l'université pour
faire du présentiel que ce soit en td ou
en cours et donc ce qu'on va construire
c'est une solution pour le deuxième
semestre qui consistera à dire un
étudiant ou une étudiante a le droit
d'avoir 20 % de son temps en présentiel
et on doit essayer de tenir c'est à dire
un jour sur cinq et on doit essayer de
tenir aussi pour que les jauges comme on
dit ce terme est affreux mais que ce
soit jamais plus de 20% face à la
détresse psychologique qui semble gagner
de plus en plus de jeunes emmanuel
macron a confirmé la création d'un
chèque psy qui permettra de pouvoir
consulter un psychologue et suivre des
soins
mais la sortie de crise semble encore
bien loin le chef de l'état a prévenu
que le retour à la normale ne se ferait
pas avant la rentrée de septembre 2021
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
romain geste un étudiant en droit à
paris un porte parole de la cocarde
étudiantes vont soir romain jestin merci
d'être avec nous avant d'aller dans le
détail des mesures un de faire réagir à
ces mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron globalement est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que le gouvernement et le
président ont pris conscience
de votre détresse oui on peut dire qu'il
ya une prise de conscience parce que
depuis le début de la crise finalement
les étudiants ce sont les oubliés le
problème c'est que durant le premier
confinement 31% d'entre eux ont présenté
des signes de détresse psychologique et
on a eu un deuxième confinement là vous
parlez dans votre reportage d'un
possible troisième confinement jusqu'où
est ce que ça va aller donc on a une
prise de conscience maintenant on attend
des actes
alors les actes et il y en a eu
peut-être vous allez me dire ou non
première mesure annoncée et accès à deux
repas par jour pour le prix d'un euro le
repas dans l'est resté dans les restos u
afin de leur permettre donc de faire
face aux conséquences cette fois-ci
économiques de la crise ce que c'est une
bonne mesure elle nss elle était
nécessaire évidemment au bout oui
nécessaire c'est une bonne mesure
c'est c'est la seule bonne mesure
d'ailleurs qu'on peut qu'on peut retenir
et ça répond à une détresse
effectivement financière de la part de
certains de certains étudiants des
étudiants qui sont parfois ne
bénéficient pas des bourses
c'est là vraiment l'intérêt de la mesure
c'est d'ouvrir ses repas à l'ensemble
des étudiants après sur les deux autres
mesures qui soutient ont été mises en
avant la première c'est adrien dentz et
le chèque soutien psychologique et alors
là c'est assez marrant c'est qu'on
préfère s'attaquer aux conséquences
plutôt qu'aux causes c'est à dire est-ce
qu'à la fin de l'année
il va falloir mettre un psy par étudiant
si la situation n'évolue pas la vraie
solution pour répondre à la détresse
psychologique c'est de rouvrir les facs
et la deuxième mesure qui va dans ce qui
semble aller dans ce sens puisqu'il nous
dit d'ouvrir les facs avec un présentiel
il serait d'un jour sur cinq mois je
vais vous le dire c'est techniquement
quasi impossible j'étais élue à paris 1
jusqu'en novembre
j'ai vu comment ça s'est passé la mise
en place on avait eu d'une semaine
alterné donc une semaine sur deux les
étudiants pouvaient aller à la fac
mettre en place un système où les
étudiants ne pourrait venir 15 jours sur
5 pour troller ça savoir à quel cours et
ce qui pourrait aller enfin pourquoi
est-ce que certains viendrait-elle jour
et les autres tels joue
maintenir en même temps un distant ciel
parce que ceux qui sont à la fac
forcément pendant ce temps certains sont
chez eux
tout ça ça me paraît techniquement
faisable le seul système c'est de ré
ouvrir complètement les facs ou alors de
retourner au système de semaine alternée
voilà est-ce que clairement pour vous
c'est un effet d'annoncé parce que c'est
vrai que on a du mal à imaginer
l'efficacité d'une seule journée de
cours oui c'est un c'est en effet
d'annonce mais le gouvernement et les
spécialistes dans ce domaine mais moi
j'aimerais porter encore plus haut que
que la question de l'université la
parole des étudiants
la question de la priorité c'est qu'on
revienne à une vie normale je crois je
crois que les chiffres les jeunes qui
sont atteints qui qui sont décédés du
cobp ide et qui n'avait pas de
comorbidité je crois que c'est une
soixantaine de jeunes sur sur cette
crise sur cette pandémie et donc est ce
qu'on a vraiment envie de sacrifier
toute une génération sur plusieurs mois
sur bientôt une année pour sauver
quelques quelques quelques étudiants et
enfin quelques jeunes et encore une fois
les personnes à risque pourrait très
bien rester chez elle et bénéficier
dudit essentielle quand et autres
pourraient de se rendre à la fac on a
quand même l'impression que les mesures
prises sont disproportionnées je lisais
que les étudiants faisait en ce moment
les élèves de terminale en tout cas leur
leurs souhaits pour parcours suppose ils
veulent choisir la fac les écoles bref
ils émettent des voeux apparemment
l'université la faculté boudé par les
élèves de terminale de cette année vous
estimez que les facs sont les parents
pauvres
aujourd'hui oui elles sont plus ou moins
sacrifiés on voit que les cours en prépa
continue dans les écoles la plupart des
cours continuent enfin c'est vrai que
l'image de l'université quand elle n'est
pas bloqué aujourd'hui bon on interdit
on interdit aux jeunes d'y aller et ça
donne pas envie et pourtant c'est moi
j'y suis et c'est quelque chose de
formidable je peux que conseiller si
déjà nous écoutent d'aller d'aller à
l'université
on a des professeurs remarquable et
c'est vraiment triste d'en arriver à une
telle situation aujourd'hui
globalement quelle serait la première
mesure que vous attendriez la
réouverture totale des facultés c'est
bien ça oui
la réouverture totale des facultés il
quand les gestes barrière ne peuvent pas
être ne peuvent pas être possible
matériellement parce qu'il faut pas être
floue on ne peut pas de demander
l'impensable non plus et bien revenir à
ce système de semaine alternée qui je le
rappelle est s'était fait alors pour la
plupart des facultés en septembre
octobre et ceux qui étaient chez eux
parce qu'ils étaient voilà dans leur
semaine chez eux et bien des caméras
avaient été installées dans les
amphithéâtres donc c'est tout à fait
possible et une partie pouvait
bénéficier des cours en présentiel et ça
permettait de garder ce qui est
essentiel au delà de la question
économique à laquelle il a répondu
financière avec seul sert pas la
question du lien social
cette nécessité de maintenir un lien
social et de ne pas être simplement des
zombies devant devant nos écrans à faire
des heures et des heures de deux de
cours par voilà par écran interposé ça
n'a absolument aucun sens merci beaucoup
en tout cas romain jestin d'avoir
témoigné en direct sur arte france
la crise sanitaire en europe l'allemagne
a tranché et a décidé de prolonger les
confinements jusqu'au 14 février
prochain un confinement qui s'accompagne
de mesures plus strictes
on fait le point avec notre
correspondant à berlin à pitaro lille
mardi angela merkel a rencontré les
dirigeants des 16 états allemands ils
ont décidé de prolonger le confinement
jusqu'au 14 février ainsi que
d'introduire des mesures plus strictes
notamment il faudra porter des masques
de qualité médicale dans les magasins
les transports entre autres lieux
plusieurs régions allemandes ont
également commencé à mettre en place des
centres de quarantaine forcée pour ceux
qui transgressent de manière répétée les
restrictions sanitaires et les autorités
ont insisté sur le fait qu'il s'agirait
là d'un dernier recours
précédé par des avertissements des
amendes et qu'il reviendrait un tribunal
le qualifier des risques directs ces
centres existants saxe dans le bade
wurtemberg où schleswig-holstein le
brandebourg et la ville état de berlin
ont déclaré vouloir leur emboîter le pas
le gouvernement de la bavière l'un des
états allemands les plus touchés par la
pandémie a dit se réserver le droit de
placer en détention ce qui ne respectent
pas la quarantaine ou refusent de se
mettre en quarantaine la région de hesse
avait déjà créé un tel centre l'année
dernière puis il avait fermé faute de
besoins
plusieurs états ont déclaré ne pas
souhaiter s'engager dans cette voie la
thuringe par exemple affirme ne pas
considérer cette solution pour le moment
mais un certain nombre d'états comme je
les dis
ont déjà mis en place ou s'apprêtent à
mettre en place de telles sommes il est
important de souligner que selon les
sondages la majorité des allemands
acceptent de se plier aux mesures
adoptées
cependant certains signes indiquent que
la limite pour être proche plus tôt
cette semaine avant la réunion entre
angela merkel et les seize dirigeants
des régions allemandes
un sondage indiquait que seuls 28 % des
allemands considérer des mesures plus
strict nécessaire
il s'agit d'une baisse de 21% ce qui
suggère que les allemands ont atteint
leurs limites
particulièrement avec l'idée que des
anciens centres de réfugiés des hôpitaux
sécurisé ou même des centres de
détention pour mineurs par exemple
pourrait à l'avenir accueillir ceux qui
transgressent les règles sanitaires de
manière répétée deuxième pays au monde
le plus endeuillé par la pandémie le
brésil qui a débuté sa campagne de
vaccination au début de semaine une
lueur d'espoir dans un avenir sanitaire
incertain l'apparition d'un nouveau
variant brésilien rend la situation hors
de contrôle
quentin mauclair à 107 ans cette femme
de la communauté indigène a reçu une
dose de vaccin ce mercredi le brésil a
commencé à vacciner massivement sa
population dans la banlieue de sao paulo
les villageois voit l'arrivée du sérum
d'un très bon oeil
c'est nous sommes très heureux de faire
partie des premières personnes à se
faire vacciner ici dans l'état de sao
paulo et dans notre communauté qui est
une très grande population
la vaccination a aussi débuté à manaus
capitale de l'état d'amazonas dont le
système sanitaire est à la limite de
l'effondrement selon le ministre de la
santé brésilien l'apparition d'un
nouveau variant a provoqué une flambée
épidémique dans cette ville située en
plein milieu de la forêt amazonienne
l'arrivée des vaccins apporte donc une
lueur d'espoir
notre lutte est une question de vie ou
de mort
nos efforts visent à sauver des vies
plus nous y parviendrons
plus les gens seront sauvés et nous
pourrons y parvenir si nous sommes dit
que dieu nous bénisse tous merci
il y a quelques jours ces images de
manaus avait fait le tour du monde
les hôpitaux étant saturés les
brésiliens faisait la queue pour
récupérer de l'oxygène et ainsi aider
leurs proches en insuffisance
respiratoire à cause du coq 19 mardi
le venezuela est venu à la rescousse de
cette ville coupée du reste du brésil
plusieurs cas nous vénézuéliens ont
apporté 132 1000 litres d'oxygène pour
approvisionner la ville de plus de deux
millions d'habitants recevoir cette
charge d'oxygène du venezuela pour la
ville de manaus est très important pour
équilibrer l'approvisionnement en
oxygène au réseau de santé public
d'amazonas
nous traversons une période difficile en
matière d'approvisionnement et toute
aide toute donation que nous recevons
est la bienvenue en particulier cette
grosse donation qui vient du venezuela
nous remercions le peuple vénézuélien de
l'affection qu'il porte à la ville de
manaus dans l'état d'amazonas et lui
adressons nos plus sincères
remerciements et notre gratitude pour le
soutien qu'ils nous apportent lundi le
brésil a lancé sa campagne de
vaccination au pied du christ rédempteur
de rio de janeiro un acte symbolique
dans un des pays les plus meurtries par
le cos vite 19 avec plus de deux cent
onze mille morts depuis le début de la
pandémie
le brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde derrière les états
unis et cuba souhaite vacciner toute sa
population 2021 même si lille a
relativement été épargné par la pandémie
est la phase de production du
candidat-vaccin soberanes à
et de et déjà entamé un vaccin qui
profiterait également au venezuela à la
bolivie ou au nicaragua amaya sous les
100 millions c'est le nombre de doses de
vaccins que cuba souhaite produire en
le directeur général de l'institut filet
du vaccin à la havane pilote deux des
quatre projets de vaccins parmi lesquels
soberanes à 2 le candidat vaccin le plus
avancé à ce stade nous prévoyons
certainement de produire jusqu'à 100
millions de doses de soberanes à deux
c'est le vaccin le plus avancé
actuellement si tout se passe bien pour
nous cette année nous faisons vacciner
toute la population cubaine des
touristes auront également la
possibilité s'ils le souhaitent de se
faire vacciner à cuba c'est court mais
les autorités n'ont déclaré aucun effet
négatif sur les premiers tests la phase
2b a donc débuté ce lundi
quelques 900 volontaires ont passé les
essais cliniques
si cette phase est réussie la troisième
pourra débuter et impliquera cent
cinquante mille volontaires en mars
prochain
la dernière étape avant approbation du
vaccin
l'objectif étant de débuter la campagne
au premier semestre 2021
outre soberanes à deux trois autres
candidats sont en préparation à des
stades moins avancés soberanes à 1
contre les variantes du virus ainsi que
abdallah aimant by sa si cuba fait
partie des pays les moins touchés par la
pandémie avec un peu plus de 19000 cas
il n'en reste pas moins impliqué dans sa
lutte
un vaccin gratuit et non obligatoire qui
va également être testé sur la
population iranienne
grâce à l'accord signé entre l'institut
pasteur d'iran et cuba le 7 janvier
dernier sur l'île où un quart du budget
est consacré à la santé
ce vaccin est perçu comme une lueur
d'espoir le pays connaît malgré tout en
léger rebond épidémique
là où l'embargo américain pèse depuis
1962 cuba dû développer ses propres
vaccins depuis plus de 30 ans
plus de 80% des vaccins du programme
national d'immunisation sont produits
par des laboratoires cubain d'où la
volonté de commercialiser leurs propres
vaccins
la stratégie de cuba pourquoi
mercialys et le vaccin est une
combinaison qui dans un premier temps se
concentre sur l'humain et l'impact sur
la santé et dans un deuxième temps
s'intéresse à la nécessité pour notre
entreprise de maintenir la production du
vaccin et des médicaments pour le pays
sauvé rana 2 serait alors le premier
vaccin anti qu'ovide d'amérique latine
un avantage non négligeable pour le sous
continent qui ne dépendrait pas des
laboratoires internationaux
autre atout selon les autorités
sanitaires le vaccin ne nécessiterait
pas de conditions particulières de
réfrigération et pour en parler nous
sommes avec pascal drouhaud président de
l'association france amérique latine
bonsoir pascal gros merci d'être avec
nous alors que baky espère en produire
100 millions de doses de son vaccin
contre le corps d'un virus cette année
en 2021 qui souhaitent vacciner toute sa
population et à lens est donc la phase
de production du candidat-vaccin
soberanes à compenser vous c'est un
objectif ambitieux mais réalisable ou
c'est un effet d'annonce je dirais que
bien évidemment qu'il y a il est un peu
des deux pourquoi parce qu'en fait le
continent latino américain ce sont plus
de 20 pays
il est ce qui se passe à cuba révèle
justement la diversité du conti dans
plus de 20 pays + 2 autant de
différences nationales dans l'ensemble
du continent ce qui unit l'amérique
latine aujourd'hui c'est ce combat de
tous les jours contre une pandémie qui
ravage les économies et qui renforce les
fractures sociales
c'est ça le véritable défi de l'amérique
latine aujourd'hui et en incluant en
effet la région des caraïbes 33 pays
33 différence de situation mais avec un
élément d'unité absolue pour tous sauver
l'économie du continent très rapidement
15 millions de cas dans un continent de
600 millions d'habitants
mais depuis un an depuis que la cofidis
9 est devenue une pandémie
internationale ce sont 200 millions de
personnes qui ont basculé dans l'extrême
pauvreté ou dans la pauvreté sur un
ensemble de 600 millions c'est ça le
véritable défi
alors en effet certains pays de
l'amérique latine et des caraïbes
propose des vaccins en tout cas y
travaillent
il faut s'en féliciter mais sur l'autre
front
c'est évidemment de sauver les économies
du continent alors justement cuba
pourraient faire profiter le venezuela
la bolivie le nicaragua vous vous y
croyez justement à cette cette belle
unité parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
ce à quoi on assiste nécessairement
ailleurs dans le monde cette générosité
cette solidarité médicale oui je crois
surtout qu'il faut sortir d'un seul axe
politique les pays que vous citez sont
des pays importants bien évidemment mais
qui s'inscrivent dans un un axe
politique dans un ensemble comme je vous
dis si cet ensemble ils comptent 33 pays
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a il existe
cette solidarité mais justement elle
révèle aussi la grande faiblesse qui
actuel de l'amérique latine
la grande faiblesse c'est cette
désintégration des coopérations
régionales
chaque pays depuis un an s'occupe avant
tout de la situation nationale alors
même qu' il existe des unions régionales
dans l'ensemble de l'amérique latine et
des caraïbes
autant dans l'union d'ailleurs des
caraïbes que sur la façade pacifique
l'alliance du pacifique en amérique
centrale système d'intégration ou en
amérique du sud avec par exemple
mercredi jour donc autant d'union qui en
fait ont disparu depuis un an et c'est
ça le véritable problème c'est que il va
falloir véritablement alors que
l'amérique latine et la région des
caraïbes sont aujourd'hui dos au mur
créer une nouvelle dynamique et
peut-être en effet bâtir un nouveau
contrat social
ces salles élément d'unité à l'échelle
du continent parce que véritablement
aujourd'hui d'amérique centrale amérique
latine et vous l'avez rappelé dans votre
reportage est un des continents les plus
touchés par cette pandémie est
aujourd'hui doit relever véritablement
ce défi c'est un défi sanitaire mais pas
simplement il s'agit véritablement
aujourd'hui de bâtir un nouveau contrat
social avec tous alors parce qu'à drouot
ça c'est pour la partie économies
effectivement mais on on a on peut se
poser la question quand on voit que la
france a toujours pas son vaccin on est
bien à la traîne l'une des plus grandes
puissances mondiales
qu'est ce qui fait que cocu bah
justement a déjà trouvé un vaccin
on dit souvent voilà que lille a été
sous embargo américain depuis 1962 et
qu'elle a dû prouver ses propres
médicaments ses propres remèdes même si
on sait que l'embargo n'avait pas lieu
sur les la santé mais sur les banques
donc ça a compliqué les choses et au
cube a dû trouver ses propres ressources
plus bas à est très pertinent
scientifique cuba est très performant
sur le plan scientifique et donc
vraisemblablement le cube a travaillé
depuis un an à la recherche d'un vaccin
mais je voudrais réintégrer moi toute
cette réalité dans celle de l'ensemble
du continent et c'est ce continent unis
dans la crise mais totalement divers
parce qu'avec les caraïbes 33 pays
trente trois réalités réalités
différentes qui le caractérise qui
véritablement aujourd'hui le véritable
défi d'un continent félicitons-nous que
des pays comme cuba puisse prochainement
annoncer un vaccin
simplement il ya une réalité politique
dans l'ensemble du continent avec une
diversité avec de vrais points de
fracture
pensez vous réellement que le brésil va
accepter le vaccin cubain c'est ça la
réalité la réalité du terrain
merci en tout cas excuser moi on arrive
au bout tête ont toutes un merci pascal
drouhaud d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
charte des principes pour l'islam de
france a prouvé ce dimanche et qui sont
déjà compromise trois fédérations du csm
refusé de la signer
les associations qui composent le
conseil français du culte musulman
sont-elles représentative des musulmans
de france ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fond dans la politique c'est
la rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs et
plus qu'à des réalités ça comme
conséquence que la politique est devenue
un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique
trop de lois tuent la loi d' et les lois
inutiles culé vol nwa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france
approuvé dimanche la charte des
principes pour l'islam de france sont
déjà compromise dans un communiqué
commun 1 trois fédérations du cfcm
exprime leur refus de le signer selon
eux en l'état actuel des choses le texte
est de nature à fragiliser les liens de
confiance entre les musulmans de france
est la nation
[Musique]
mais alors que cinq des neuf fédérations
du cfcm ont paraphé le document trois
ans donc refusé de signer cette charte
des principes pour un islam de france
voulue par emmanuel macron marine le pen
s'est emparé du sujet la présidente du
rassemblement national demande la
dissolution de cette instance mise en
place en 2003 par nicolas sarkozy alors
ministre de l'intérieur
alors question faut-il dissoudre le cfcm
les associations qui composent le
conseil français du culte musulman
sont-elles représentative des musulmans
de france
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soit avec nous pour en parler anouar
kbibech vice-président du cfcm président
du rassemblement des musulmans de france
l'une des huit associations qui
composent le cfcm bonsoir à vous à noah
kbibech vous êtes en direct par
téléphone eric diard député les
républicains des bouches du rhône
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être là
alors emmanuel macron qui a donc laissé
quinze jours à eau non signataires pour
clarifier leur position bientôt une
semaine de passer toujours rien silence
radio certains dénoncent une fracture au
sein du conseil français du culte
musulman avant de réagir je vous propose
de regarder le tweet du journaliste
franco algérien à mohamed sifaoui deux
associations islamistes turcs ccmtf
emilie gourd us ainsi que foi et
pratique signe communiqué pour dire
qu'elle rejette la charte des principes
pour un islam de france
cette clarification idéologique doit
impliquer leur exclusion du cfcm kbibech
ya véritablement une césure vous êtes
confiant les frondeurs entre guillemets
vont rentrer dans le rang et signés non
il ne faut pas dramatiser les choses
nous avons mené depuis le 18 février
pardon le 18 novembre quand le président
de la république nous a reçus pour lui
présenter les documents déclaratif et
constitutif du conseil national des
images nous avons
ac c'est le principe de la mise au point
des sharks étaient principes
républicains et une charte des principes
de l'islam de france
nous y avons travaillé depuis deux mois
il y avait pratiquement un consensus sur
l'ensemble des principes et figure sur
serge cette charte
par contre il ya un certain nombre de
fournir à sion sur lesquels les trois
fédérations qui n'ont pas signé pour le
moment souhaité prendre un peu plus de
temps pour consulter leurs instances
respectives et pour le moment
manifestement ses convives à sion le
rose encore problème mais j'espère que
dans les prochains jours la situation se
débloquera et qu'on relancera le
processus de création du conseil
national des humains qui a mené à agréer
des zidane est là à les accompagner en
termes de formation et de travail sur
leur statut alors dans leur a
effectivement du fond de ce qui les
empêche de signer parce que les
désaccords sont tout de même profond
pour certains qu'on a pu d'ailleurs
avoir sur notre antenne
côté politique eric diard marine le pen
s'est emparé de ce sujet écoutez ce
tweet d'hyères de la patronne du
rassemblement national
alors le gouvernement doit procéder à
leur dissolution
marine le pen c'est courant qui
demandent la dissolution tout simplement
du cfcm créé par nicolas sarkozy en 2003
la question de fond c'est cela il faut
tout simplement supprimée cet instant
selon vous il ya moi je vous dirais mais
pour m quoi il faut pas oublier que
cette instance
il faut bien n'a aucune aucun pouvoir
coercitif évidemment sur les différentes
mouvances premièrement deuxièmement
c'est un organe de concertation et qui
rassemble donc les différentes mouvances
dessus islam on pourrait dissoudre mais
pour le remplacer par quoi aujourd'hui
il n'y a rien mais nous avons je suis
orateurs dont vous savez la commission
spéciale sur la loi qui renforce les
principes républicains la semaine
dernière nous avons auditionné le
président du conseil du culte musulman
je lui posais la question justement par
rapport à ce qu'avait dit monsieur
sifaoui dans le jdd puisqu'il y avait eu
trois mouvances qui avait claqué la
porte
aujourd'hui il y en a une ça change et
je crois que musulmans de france
vous êtes vous avez signé maintenant
vous avez signé la charte
mais bon il était assez pessimiste sur
la temps l'entente parce que quand même
il faut pas oublier que de le il y a
quand même des premières mentant sur
internent je les sentais déjà entre le
recteur à la mosquée et le président et
le président et il ya aussi les
influences étrangères qui n'arrange pas
le tout anouar kbibech seuil n'est pas
là le fond du problème justement ces
influences étrangères
on rappelle l'un des enjeux est le plus
sensible certainement de cette charte
c'est la création d'un conseil national
des imams qui sera chargée de entre
guillemets labelliser les imams exerçant
en france précisément quand on sait que
ces fédérations sont financés par les
pays étrangers à ce conflit d'intérêts
ce que c'est pas là justement le
problème de fond déjà une petite
précision moi je suis le prix les
longues rassemblement des musulmans de
france ils ont de l'île de france et je
suis ancien président du cld donc à ce
titre en tant que président du rmf nous
avons contribué à l'élaboration de cette
charte est parmi les points essentiels
dans cette charte c'est le refus de
l'ingérence étrangère dans la gestion
des pays musulmans en france et
l'ensemble des fédérations composant le
cfcm sont d'accord sur ce principe
maintenant le fait qu'il y ait cinq
fédérations qui ont signé et 3 qui
prenne un peu de temps pour le faire ne
remet pas en cause de kate qui lie à
unanimité de la part de tous et des
fédérations pour rejeter le linge et les
ingérences étrangères pour rejeter
l'islam politique
nous faisons de la religion et non de la
politique et pour affirmer que les
valeurs de l'islam sont totalement
compatibles avec les valeurs et les lois
de la république et c'est ça l'essence
même de cette charte
des principes de l'islam de france est
et c'est bien comme ça noir au cabinet
chaque qu'on vous avait présenté à
l'instant et que vous êtes présenté sur
notre antenne n'y a pas eu d'erreur sur
ce point effectivement mais c'est vrai
monsieur dior parler de musulmans de
france ont sabré sont à moi donc je
voulais apporter ce que très bien très
bien
eric diard est-ce que selon vous vous
qui connaissez effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé très bien ce sujet est ce que
les musulmans de france se reconnaissent
alors il faudra peut-être leur pose est
évidemment la question à eux mais est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que
reconnaissent dans cet organisme août et
je ne suis pas le mieux placé pour le
dire je ne peux pas répondre à cette
question
moi je pense que malheureusement le plus
grand ennemi des musulmans c'est l'islam
politique c'est le fondamentalisme après
moi je vais vous poser une question
puisque vous êtes quand même un des
pères fondateurs j'allais dire de ce
conseil est ce que toutes les mouvances
rejette la peau stasi c'est à dire et
c'est à dire que ne considère plus la
peau stasi quand même crime
est ce que toutes les mouvances
condamner l'homophobie l'antisémitisme
et prône également l'égalité
hommes-femmes ça c'est ma question je
sais que c'est votre cas mais je pose la
question pour les mouvances qui
justement ne sont pas signataires
mais justement le fait de ratifier ce
que cette charte devrait être juré là la
preuve que l'ensemble de ses composantes
du cfcm avait à ses principes et notre
souhait c'est que dans quelques jours
toutes les fédérations qui composent le
csm se retrouvent autour de ces valeurs
qui sont affirmer haut et fort dans
cette charte et qui sont écrit noir sur
blanc le rejet de toute forme de
discrimination sur toute la salle un
certain nombre de critères l'attachement
à l'égalité notamment l'égalité en train
ne rejet de toute forme de racisme que
ce soient les actes anti-musulmans les
actes antisémites et toute forme de
racisme et de discrimination
ce sont des valeurs fortes qui sont
proclamés dans cette charte est
justement c'est un acte fondateur dans à
la fois la refondation des relations
entre
le culte musulman en france et les
pouvoirs publics mais également et la
république surtout est également un acte
fondateur auprès de l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes de confession musulmane ou
qu'ils adhèrent à ces valeurs-là & kill
kill qu'ils assurent leur promotion pour
renforcer le vivre ensemble au voulez
vous faire réagir sur cette réaction de
tareq oubrou à le grand imam de bordeaux
qui s'est exprimé sur cette charte
écoutez c'est dommage que le cfcm
produit ce texte sous la pression
politique alors qu'il aurait dû prendre
l'initiative par lui-même
le conseil français du culte musulman
aurait dû déclarer théologiquement
parlant la compatibilité des valeurs de
l'islam avec les lois de la république
et lignards c'est souvent le reproche
qui est fait ce texte a été produit sous
la pression de l'exécutif
vous êtes d'accord sous la pression si
parce que hier il y avait ce texte qui
arrive et regarder en avant
comme par hasard il a été signé dimanche
alors que que l'étude en commission
commencé dès le lundi à mon avis il ya
une pression mais moi je suis quand même
inquiet parce que j'ai écouté le
président moussaoui attentive à manger
je vous écoute et guay et j'ai écouté
également mohamed sifaoui
il ya certains mouvements
fondamentalistes qui ne reconnaissent
pas certaines valeurs de la république
et c'est pour cela il me semble qu'ils
ne veulent pas signer cette charte
anouar kbibech justement le 7e qui
aurait dû prendre selon l'imam de
bordeaux
l'initiative par lui même
c'était la meilleure solution pour
justement qu'il n'y ait pas discussions
et cette initiative a été prise par les
musulmans et par le ca sion depuis les
années conduit président du sexuel de
2015 à 2017 il ya déjà les sharks des
imams qui a été élaboré à l'initiative
exclusive du sel il a été généralisée à
l'ensemble des régions de france à
travers les crcm les conseillers
régionaux du culte musulman
cette fois on va encore plus loin par la
mise en place d'une nouvelle instance
qui est le conseil national des imams
qui est composé à moitié d'un collège
des président du csm et à moitié par un
collège
mende référents de chaque fédération
donc c'est une étape supplémentaire et
le fait de de l'hôtel de cette charte
des principes devraient pouvoir s'y fier
et clarifier les relations entre le
culte musulman en france et la
république et je pense que ce qui s'est
passé lundi à l'elysée avec sa signature
solennelle de cette charte par cinq
fédérations sur les huit qui composent
le cn est un acte fondateur importants
historiques qui est du même niveau que
que l'accord qui a été trouvé par
napoléon bonaparte en 1807 avec les
représentants du culte israélites donc
il faut pas minimiser cet acte il se
passe un peu dans la difficulté dans la
mesure où certaines fédérations
souhaitent avoir un peu plus de temps
pour judy gréer faire adopter les
formulations qui se trouvent dans cette
charte par leurs instances
il faut donner du temps au temps comme
envié dans quelques jours j'espère que
nous nous retrouverons tout ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure pour constituer ce
conseiller national daily main qui
n'exclura personne
vous avez cité tout à l'heure car et
couvrons tard et couvrons est une
référence et une respectable et animale
qui a sa place dans le paysage actuel en
france et le conseiller national
déliement aura les meilleures relations
avec des imans comme le grand imam de
bordeaux
merci à tous les deux merci en tout cas
à tous les deux noirs en kbibech et
erika d'avoir accepté ce débat merci
aux etats unis joe biden se met au
travail dans une amérique divisé à peine
installé à la maison blanche le 46e
président des états unis a signé une
quinzaine de décret pour tourner la page
trump direction maintenant washington
pour retrouver notre envoyé spécial
thomas bonnet bonsoir avons plutôt
bonjour thomas pour vous après une
journée de célébration qu'on a vécu en
direct sur air et france joe biden doit
donc désormais se pencher sur un certain
nombre de dossiers brûlants
oui et joe biden a voulu donner l'image
d'un président déjà à la tâche dès hier
on a pu voir les images du nouveau
président des états unis en train de
prendre ses quartiers à la maison
blanche notamment dans le bureau ovale
bureau sur lequel était disposée une
dizaine de décrets pour montrer qu'il
n'y a pas de temps à perdre c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui avait twitté joe biden
quelques minutes seulement après son
investiture parmi les premières mesures
qui ont été prises par le nouveau
président des états unis la plupart
viser clairement à effacer un certain
nombre de politiques qui avaient été
mises en place par l'administration
trump sur des thématiques telles que le
climat l'immigration ou encore
l'économie je vous propose d'écouter les
premiers mots de joe biden depuis le
bureau ovale ici à la maison blanche
compte tenu de l'état de la nation il
n'y a pas de temps à perdre il faut se
mettre au travail immédiatement
comme nous l'avons déjà annoncé nous
allons signer un certain nombre de
décrets dans la semaine et je vais
commencer aujourd'hui sur la crise
combinée du président du comice 19 et de
la crise économique qui a suivi et sur
la crise climatique et les questions
d'équité raciale certaines des mesures
exécutive que je vais signer aujourd'hui
vont contribuer à inverser le cours de
la grise de que vide et nous allons
combattre le changement climatique comme
nous ne l'avons jamais fait jusqu'ici et
faire progresser les kits et raciales et
soutenir les autres communautés mal
desservies
nous allons également reconstruire notre
économie joe biden a également présenté
il ya quelques instants à peine sa
stratégie pour lutter contre la pandémie
de kobe 19 on sait que l'administration
baden souhaite renforcer les
restrictions sanitaires mais également
répandre l'utilisation du masque dans
tout le pays on a appris par exemple il
ya quelques minutes qu'une quarantaine
sera désormais obligatoire pour toute
personne arrivant aux états unis par
avion alors thomas autre chantier pour
joe biden tenter de réconcilier m
eric divisée comment réagissent les
républicains aux mesures prises par le
nouveau président
évidemment l'opposition est déjà forte
contre les mesures engagées par joe
biden les mesures contre l'immigration
par exemple sont contestés mais ce qui a
provoqué le plus de réactions
c'est le fait que les états unis
réintègre la corde paris sur le climat
écouté par exemple la réaction de tête
cruz sénateur républicain du texas est
proche de donald trump écouter en
signant ce décret le président biden
montrent qu'ils s'intéressent plus aux
opinions des citoyens de paris qu aux
emplois des citoyens de pittsburgh
rejoindre la corde paris ne consiste pas
à restaurer le leadership américain à
l'étranger ou à résoudre la crise
climatique mais il s'agit plutôt des
projets des démocrates de détruire les
emplois qu'ils n'aiment pas y compris
des milliers d'emplois dans le secteur
manufacturier et perdre le contrôle de
nos énergies futures et le procureur
général du texas a même déjà fait savoir
qu'il pourrait lancer des procédures en
justice pour contester les décisions de
joe biden certaines organisations de
l'état du texas craignent justement les
répercussions de la politique
environnementale de joe biden sur
l'économie de cet état qui est très liée
à l'exploitation des ressources
naturelles
alors thomas rabe du côté des supporters
de donald trump qu'elles sont cloche
après cette cérémonie d'investiture
forcément beaucoup de déception pour les
supporters de donald trump ou voyez
passer certains messages sur les réseaux
sociaux qui certains espéraient encore
un ultime retournement de situation lors
de cette cérémonie d'investiture
évidemment cela n'a pas eu lieu il ya eu
quelques petits rassemblements ces
derniers jours de la part de supporters
de donald trump devant les capitals de
certains états du pays beaucoup de
supporters de l'ancien président
continue de penser que l'élection leur a
été volé il remet donc en cause la
légitimité du nouveau locataire de la
maison blanche est évidemment la plupart
rejettent également les mesures prises
par joe biden et les regards se tournent
maintenant vers la floride le lieu où
séjourne actuellement
donald trump la question est de savoir
ce qu'a prévu l'ancien président il se
dit ici qu'il pourrait lancer un parti
politique
le patriote parties ont vu donc de
rester en politique et pourquoi pas de
tenter sa chance à nouveau pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 24 ce
qui est sûr c'est que parmi lesquels que
74 millions de ceux des lecteurs de
donald trump beaucoup continuent à le
soutenir alors vous l'aurez compris
malgré les appels à l'unité nationale
lancé par joe biden lors de la cérémonie
d'investiture la réconciliation de
l'amérique diviser ce n'est pas pour
tout de suite
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
washington
l'europe a de nouveau un ami à la maison
blanche déclaration hier de la
présidente de la commission européenne
l'union européenne en tout cas à
proposer au président américain un new
un pacte fondateur transatlantique
ursula von der leyen a vite joe biden a
participé à une réunion extraordinaire
du conseil européen à bruxelles et
précision de clément barbé avec david
luiz inouïe l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche signe hôtel l'avènement
d'une nouvelle ère dans les relations
transatlantiques
ce mercredi 20 janvier à bruxelles la
présidente de la commission européenne
s'est félicitée de l'investiture du
nouveau président des états unis après
80 années l'europe un ami à la maison
blanche cette nouvelle aube en amérique
et le moment que nous attendions depuis
si longtemps
l'europe est prête pour un nouveau
départ avec notre plus ancien et plus
fiable la liste un enthousiasme que
partage aussi le président du conseil
européen charles michel
ce dernier invite joe biden à bruxelles
et proposent un programme pour la
nouvelle relation transatlantique en
cinq points bush premièrement stimuler
les relations multilatérales
deuxièmement combattre lakovic 19
troisièmement s'attaquer aux changements
climatiques
quatrièmement reconstruire nos économies
en assurant un commerce équitable et la
transformation numérique
et cinquièmement joindre nos forces sur
la sécurité et la paix pis après quatre
ans d'une politique étrangère marqué par
l'unilatéralisme de l'administration
trump la diplomatie américaine est
désormais incarnée par anthony blinken
ce pilier du parti démocrate a plaidé
devant le sénat pour un retour au
multilatéralisme
nous pouvons revitaliser nos alliances
fondamentale multiplié notre influence à
travers le monde
ensemble nous sommes bien me placer pour
contrer les menaces de la russie de
l'iran de la corée du nord et pour
défendre la démocratie et les droits de
l'homme en plus des questions
diplomatiques l'union européenne attend
aussi la nouvelle administration
américaine sur les questions économiques
comme celle de la taxe sur les géants du
numérique une proposition plutôt bien
accueillie par la nouvelle secrétaire au
trésor une taxe internationale sur les
géants du numérique en discussion dans
le cadre de l' ocde permettrait de
percevoir une juste part des entreprises
tout en maintenant la compétitivité de
nos entreprises
une proposition en rupture totale avec
la politique de donald trump qui avait
notamment infligé plusieurs sanctions à
la france après la taxe gaffe a instauré
par paris cette arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche est scruté par le
monde entier de nouveau président des
états unis doit détailler aujourd'hui
les grandes lignes de sa politique
commerciale faut-il s'attendre à une
rupture partielle ou m totale avec le
mandat de donald trump
éléments de réponse avec nicolas petit
nous n'avons pas une seconde à perdre
pour faire face aux crises auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés joe biden a
clairement affiché ses intentions cette
semaine parmi ses priorités le président
démocrate devrait s'occuper des échanges
avec la chine dans cette perspective joe
biden ne s'éloignera pas complètement
des préceptes de son prédécesseur comme
l'a indiqué le nouveau chef de la
diplomatie amérique
anthony blinken le président de trump a
eu raison d'adopter une position plus
ferme face à la chine
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec la
façon dont il s'y est pris à plusieurs
égards mais le principe de base était le
bon cela renforce réellement notre
politique étrangère
lorsque nous regardons la chine
il ne fait aucun doute que c'est l'état
nation qui pose le plus grand défi aux
états unis en termes d'intérêt
c'est-à-dire les intérêts du peuple
américain
la défense des intérêts du peuple
américain et des entreprises c'est
précisément pour ces raisons que donald
trump avait dès 2018 engagé une guerre
commerciale contre la chine
à coups de taxes douanières
l'administration maiden accuse elle
aussi des entreprises chinoises de
pratiques illégales ou encore de vol de
propriété intellectuelle et pourrait
annoncer un arsenal d'outils adaptés
pour autant le nouveau président
démocrate souhaite visiblement mettre
fin à l'unilatéralisme initiée par
donald trump sortie des accords de
vienne sur le nucléaire iranien en mai
les etats-unis ont rétabli les sanctions
américaines à l'égard de l'iran embargo
sur les produits pétroliers le secteur
aéronautique et miniers par exemple
d'après le successeur de maipu pompéo
joe biden seraient prêts à adopter une
autre attitude à condition que téhéran
respecte à nouveau ses engagements le
président pense que si l'iran revient
dans les clous nous le ferons aussi nous
utiliserions cela comme un point de
départ avec nos alliés et partenaires
qui serait à nouveau du même côté que
nous pour rechercher un accord plus fort
et plus durable
autre symbole de ce changement de cap
joe biden souhaiterait jouer la carte de
l'apaisement dans la taxation des gaffes
à une décision qui ne sera certainement
pas pour déplaire à paris actuellement
axé sur de nombreux produits pour avoir
décidé d'imposer davantage les géants du
numérique qui ne paient pas d'impôts ou
presque en france c'est la fin de cette
émission vous retrouver dans quelques
instants pierre pissavy yvernault pour
un point complet sur la qualité
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire cannes